[Music]
when people look at me all they see is
the spoiled daughter of the hotel magnet
I just want people to remember me for
more than my last name my lady
exactly are we going
Sierra Belmont
the last year with you has been truly
magical
will you marry me oh it's hard
I've got you
[Music]
is it a dead body
sure could you please tell her to let me
out of here first we need to figure out
who you are what do you mean who I am my
name is
my name is so what are we supposed to do
with her I have a place
does it have room service
[Music]
where am I alrighty you went through the
lost and found are these used probably
but you know sometimes guests leave
things here by accident so I'm not sure
this was left here by accident
the doctor did say that if I did normal
things my memory might come back
doctor's orders
have you ever actually made a bed deer
I don't think so
in almost two days no one's found me yet
like unclaimed luggage
to probably I'm looking for you right
now find my daughter
you like her don't you oh yeah I think
you should tell her
wow look beautiful
[Music]
sometimes you can't rush things
I need to find my own way
[Music]
foreign
week what do you know about the royal
family of aldovia the king died last
year and the prince who's supposed to
take over is a total slate and
scandalous socialite why me you're a
talented hungry smart and none of my
regular writers can go this week
this assignment could jump start your
career
wow
I'm actually inside the palace
this is better than an exclusive get
lots of video audio whatever you can
grab
hi
[Music]
ready hang on
I'm gonna get you oh
you seem rather fascinated with my
brother I heard people say you didn't
want to give up your lifestyle what
lifestyle is that I don't know women
wine and song
is that what do you think
I don't really know who you are
I I will come tomorrow night tomorrow
night
Christmas Eve ball what's going on
complete makeover
[Music]
why are they staring because you look
perfect
[Music]
oh this is lovely place for a cane
without a queen
[Music]
you may find this hard to believe but
long ago nobody knew about Christmas it
started with a boy called Nicholas and a
summons from the King I'm asking you to
go to the very edges of our kingdom and
bring back a spark of magic to give us
hope I'm going to our film to find the
elves Mika to bring some New Hope to the
world such a fool everyone knows there
is no such thing as elves you ready old
friend born ready you can talk and I can
fly as well no just kidding no mice can
fly that would be absurd
it's a dangerous Journey snail film
under the moon plus the sleeping Giants
up the pointy Mountain
we'll get there I know we will
[Music]
he's a human will he eat us where am I
there's nothing here to see something
you must believe in it
really believe
it's incredible I'm gonna be honest kid
I did not see this one working out for
us what is this what is this this is a
Christmas party it's cake City
no idea what this Christmas thing is but
all right
is that I'm Nicholas
no humans can ever be brought here
no we're duped
[Music]
King asked for Hope could you make more
lots more and we haven't much time and I
haven't much cheese
there's magic in you
[Music]
magic is real
ridiculous showed the world
thing can happen
[Music]
[Music]
it's just one day a year what should we
call it Nicholas and Mika the talking
Mouse day any other ideas
foreign
we all grow up fantasizing about finding
true love with a knight in shining armor
and living happily ever after but that's
all it is fantasy
[Music]
fear not I've been thrown much further
by much faster horses than your steel
steed
but apparently he believes that he's a
14th century Knight so called
Christopher Frederick lines of narch At
Your Service homeboy
[Music]
and that lyrical medley on the radio
I'm going to help until his memory comes
back what if he's dangerous
trust me he's harmless first thing I
think we should do is update her
wardrobe by at least a few centuries
greetings
greetings I'll let you get dressed
you know time travel isn't a real thing
right I have traveled here and it
matters not if I understand how
and I just want to Valor and virtue
you've Aid to those who seek it
hey where you are
I fear I must return home
do you really think going along with
this little delusion is helping a
situation who are we to tell him he's
not who he says he is
sure you're not a witch
foreign
[Music]
what if there are things beyond our
comprehension
then I would say you both need to get
your heads examined
you don't have to go I have no choice
[Music]
wherever you are see any place I want to
be but no one can control their own
destiny
nice catch study another lady
[Music]
foreign
is a big deal for my family and every
year I have this problem they all have
to solve because I'm always the single
one
I think you should come home with me you
can pretend we fell in love after all
these years but it'd be so easy my
family already asked why we're not just
together all right oh thank you thank
you thank you
well slay Queen Carol you have to call
her Christmas Carol how did I not know
your mom had a holiday specific drag
name you get a parent do you get a pair
of hula Oprah oh right yeah oh of course
you guys knew that
your family really wants you to have a
relationship yes I know that's very
clear so my early Christmas present for
you is apply
a blunt I love it he loves it you're
going you're going where you go he's
going on a blind date like from grinder
oh my God
I was thinking we could grab a cup of
coffee you probably thought you were
going on a date with the hottest
smartest funniest coolest most
interesting person who was ever born
maybe I am
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
New Hampshire
these stars came with the trees I love
them I do too
girls are in my bed
of course they are
you have feelings for him like Nick and
I ever went there and didn't work out I
would lose him but what if it did work
out
the gays just know how to do stuff for
some reason
you're always obsessed with me
[Music]
this place is beautiful it's like the
perfect holiday card
snow hides a lot
it's like the space of weather you can
do a lot worse in this place trust me
tell her that you like her and I've
noticed since I was five years old it's
not that easy you just have to tell her
you want the same relationship plus
boning
[Music]
Christmas Eve bash come one come on Boom
he's gonna break up with me he would
have to be the dumbest human being on
Earth to do that like dumber than the
people who blow on ice cream before they
eat it
that girl and I have a thing have you
ever been with someone and you stay up
until like 4am just talking about
everything and you're just like I can't
believe I get to exist at the same time
as you no but like I'm really happy for
you
[Music]
I realized that life is just a bunch of
stuff you can't control what is that a
bad thing
what do you think can happen
good bad anything
[Music]
and she's hooking up with them no
they're not hooking up
[Music]
all right
I think your nipple's bleeding
[Music]
Merry Christmas and come back soon hey
boss you know the Christmas baking
contest you're always talking about
the royal family of Belgravia invites
you to compete in our Christmas baking
competition can you believe it
[Music]
it's The Nutcracker Christmas is a
magical time of year I just wish I had
someone to spend it with Christmas
wishes have been known to come true
oh I am so sorry no problem
are you lady Margaret Dela Court Duchess
montenaro Stacy de novo I think we were
destined to run into each other
I'm supposed to marry Prince Edward on
New Year's Day but I hate being in the
spotlight I want to get to know what
it's like to be a normal girl
I want to switch places with you switch
places I've become you and you become me
get out
it will only be for two days
no one would even notice Stacey de novo
how's it hanging how's it hanging a bit
much is it
[Music]
suppose it's time if you say so oh there
you are here I am I'm determined to
spend as much time together as we can
over the next few days how smashing
breakfast is ready you never burn
anything I guess I'm a bit nervous with
the big contest coming up
[Music]
here we go
are you all right
keep a close eye on The Duchess she
seems different
oh uh terribly sorry that wasn't very
dignified that's right
quite liked it actually
Christmas should be about love I've
never seen you so sentimental maybe you
don't know me that well
I didn't think things would get so
complicated so what do we do
[Music]
I don't know if I can keep this up
yep
I'm great
foreign
[Music]
he knows when you're awake
[Applause]
he knows if you've been bad or good
stop
kids aren't stupid
they know how it works
sorry Santa
check it out give me the camera
it's Santa Claus
five and in person
one night only
[Music]
you don't look like Santa Claus well
Billboards add 80 pounds
Christmas is in trouble
imagine if we all work together
I have seen a lot of strange things but
this lady you see what happens next
whoa
if you ever meet Mrs Claus maybe just
skip this part
[Music]
hey hey
you all want to go on the naughty list
all right let's get back to work
so you're vacationing in Zambia huh
let me guess you're from L.A
New York yes I take it Mr Conrad won't
be joining us two days ago he told me
that our marriage was over two hours ago
I landed here on what was supposed to be
our second honeymoon
by myself a lot of people come here to
get lost so they can be found again
thank you Yoda
oh you're coming on this too yep Tara
Collinsworth in case you want to write
my name down on a Complaint Form oh
you're the pilot
we're flying over the largest game
reserve in Africa
hang on gonna make a stop what a stop
stop her
stay in the plane hook them back
[Music]
all right
poachers kill the mama for tusks we
don't do some to help that baby we did
in two days I want to help didn't see
that one coming
hi Mom how's Safari well I took a little
detour is it gonna be okay it'll be
touch and go for a while but we will do
our best I'm in this place surrounded by
wild animals hey New York
oh
sorry
um
we are coming home right this year is
going to be Christmas in Africa what is
Christmas in Africa well I can't speak
for the whole continent but here at the
elephant orphanage they celebrate all
week and there is no shopping involved
I'm really starting to worry
see now I've got to go back home and I
don't know what I'm supposed to do with
myself maybe you're doing it here
this is how it starts we meet an
elephant and so Begins the relationship
of a lifetime take good care of my
elephant our elephant he and I we're
just friends
since you didn't get to go in your fancy
five-star Safari let me take you on one
with a little less stars like three
thinking more like two I haven't seen
you that someone in in a long time if I
have learned anything it's to not get
too attached I never meant to stay this
long you're falling in love huh
with Africa
you know what that is what mistletoe
that is definitely not mistletoe African
mistletoe
[Music]
Once Upon a Time lived to the greatest
inventor that ever there was Gerard
Merry Christmas
indeed jungle for the last 30 years
you've been promising something
Sensational I need more time
come up with the money Borrowed by
Christmas or show me the Revolutionary
invention you once promised I would lose
everything
what's wrong grandpa had a perfect life
loving family and a magical shop to an
old friend took it all
but he didn't get this
[Applause]
young lady if I know anything about your
grandfather that's something Sensational
in that
I'm buddy
whoa I'm actually flying
if I have that toy I'll be unstoppable
it's foolproof
you are pooped and there are fools fools
fools fools fools this fools
this is the only place I've ever been
where I finally felt like I belong we
have to get buddy back
[Music]
I know about losing things but the magic
to what you still have
you all right yes
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
no matter who you are no matter what you
do the magic lives inside of you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]